[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants gauche
alors nounours tu ne descend pas voir
ses deux petits amis oui je veux plus
j'ai peur qu'il ne me fasse encore une
balle que non pas ce soir ils vont être
très gentil vous le dites
bon pour le chef
pauvre loulou vaut
aux
propos de boom
boom pow
et mon petit nicolas où est il j'espère
qu'il ne me prépare pas une phase ne
fait pas trop de boue rouge nous a pas
venir son journal tranquille
à paella
au monsieur papa
[Musique]
je ne veux pas vous déranger
vos enfants son charmant
monsieur papa
[Musique]
ou
moi aussi j'veux bien fumer la pipe
papa
oui la pub de papa en beauté main au
lolo
[Musique]
braves ont annoncé qu'un chiffre à moins
que les capsules ses formes ont appelé
mais qu'est ce qu'un milieu chapeau des
papas
unical actually la cravate de papa
et qui a pris la vie de papa c'est le
nonce au nicolot mais oui si toi nord et
tu veux l'a réparé puisque tu l'a cassé
avec de la colle tiens nous allons voir
ce que tu sais faire vous allez voir
alors non
ce que tu es ville mono
nom de dieu pas bon non
vous m'ennuyer enfin je ne suis pas là
moi j'ai su que nounours et vous pouvez
la recoller tout seul votre kit que je
m'en vais là
non en bonus
ils feraient bien de prendre des
vacances non que oui alors ce qu'il est
nerveux
tenu des frais connu petite soeur fait
pour elle
[Musique]
pimprenelle et nicolas sont de petits
garnements alors pas trop mais oui
nounours ils t'ont encore fait une farce
je vous la vue du patron je vous le
futur je pense que ces deux petits amis
ont bien besoin de prendre des vacances
oui et moi aussi
uni vont pas trop en route bonne nuit
les enfants feu de pur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vaud
oh
[Musique]